teror group is it possible to have a Ral
I've asked you two questions should a
mass stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV
it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on radio
and on your smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on PE Morgan on S of a
temporary ceasefire in Gaza is extended
by two days bringing joy and relief for
more hostage families but a mountain of
pressing questions for Israel I'll put
them to government spokesman Alon
Levy Tru has divided opinion Israel was
it right to extend the deal or is it
seated in the upper hand by negotiating
with terrorists or
debate and the bombshell new book by
Megan lick spittle omed scobby takes aim
every member of the Royal's household
apart of course from two people in
Montesito does anybody in the world
believe
[Music]
it from the news building in London this
is Piers Morgan
uncensored good evening from London
welcome to PE Morgan uncensored the
temporary ceasefire in Gaza has brought
of unbridled joy in the middle of a
Relentless tragedy 50 Israeli hostages
are finally being released by Hamas 150
Palestinian prisoners and trucks
carrying much needed Aid are moving the
opposite direction for some of the
families of the Hamas hostages it's the
end of an unbearable agonizing weight
Thomas Han's daughter Emily turned nine
during her 50 days in captivity his
emotional interviews have made the
trauma of the hostage families feel
tangible for those of us who can only
begin to imagine the appalling
horrifying greef brief this is the
moment they were finally
[Music]
reunited a wonderful end to a story that
could have ended so much worse and
indeed was that was the Fate that that
poor father assumed had happened well a
two-day extension to the ceasefire means
more reunions and more aid but it also
means more difficult questions for
Israel Prim Minister Netanyahu is very
clear that war will resume with full
force as soon as this pause is over he
far less clear about what happens after
that Israel's pounding Gaza for weeks
now 77% of the entire population's been
displaced half are in shelters where 700
people share a single shower the scale
of a destruction is beyond comprehension
and Israel says it won't stop until
Hamas has been eradicated but quite
clearly Hamas still runs Gaza it's Hamas
who are negotiating the release of the
hostages and dictating the terms of that
release it's Hamas who says that more
than 14,000 people in Gaza have been
killed Israel claims that figure
includes thousands of terrorists but
where is the hard evidence to support
their claim where is the evidence that
terrorists have simply not disappeared
underground or hidden themselves among
innocent civilians who headed south
where is the plan for the future of Gaza
where do these people go back and live
if all their homes have been destroyed
netanyahu's ruled out a return for the
Palestinian Authority hinted that
Israeli occupation might be the answer
uh I think Israel will
for an indefinite period will have the
overall uh security responsibility
because we've seen what happens when we
don't have it when we don't have that
security responsibility what we have is
the eruption of uh Hamas Terror on a
scale that we couldn't imagine this a
dangerous territory for Israel has a
rapidly narrowing window of legitimacy
in Gaza President Biden is under
pressure from his supporters to speed up
the end of the fighting and America
won't accept a prolonged occupation
Israel told Palestinians to move South
in Gaza to escape the bombing now it
says it'll bomb the South too this
Bloodshed cannot continue without proof
as a plan beyond the total Destruction
of Gaza I've been picked up this weekend
by people reminding me of tweets from
2014 back then Israel launched a massive
bombardment of Gaz in response to the
murder of three Israeli teenagers in the
West Bank what happened I'm asked why
did I change my position what happen
changed my position Israel committed
atrocities in 2014 in my estimation it
was a completely disproportionate
response to what had happened it looked
more like Revenge to me than a military
strategy and President Obama told him to
call it off well during that bombardment
I asked at what point does Israel's
current military strategy become the
very terrorism it professes to be
fighting and today I'm beginning to ask
myself that exact same question well I'm
now joined by Israeli spokesman Elon
Levy Alon Levy Alon Levy thank you very
much much inde for joining me um you
heard my monologue there I've said from
the start of this conflict that I felt a
real moral quandry not about uh October
the 7th I'm crystal clear about the
horror that happened there I'm
completely clear that Israel not only
had a duty to its people to defend
itself after that but had a
responsibility to do it um the question
has always been in my mind what is a
proportionate response and as we have
this pause at the moment thank God for
the release of many of the hostages it's
also time for everybody to pause and ask
some pertinent questions of Israel about
what the real plan is here going forward
so let me start just by asking
you where does this go now uh we've got
a two two-day extension to this pause
more hostages will come out but it won't
be all of them in fact Hamas don't even
know where many of the hostages are
they're with other uh Islamic
fundamentalist groups within Gaza uh
Netanyahu has already said your prime
minister that he wants to pick up the
attacks as soon as this pause is
finished but to what end and how far
will you
go Israel's campaign now in response to
the October 7th Massacre is
proportionate to the threat that we face
and that threat is a second October 7th
third October 7th the fourth million
October 7th exactly as Hamas is
promising to do to murder every man
woman child in our country we really
wish we were not in this situation piers
and for many years Israel has been
putting off a possible campaign to
topple Hamas but the October 7th
Massacre left us no choice it was the
deadliest Massacre of Jews since the
Holocaust it was the deadliest terror
attack in world history since 911 and in
response to that our c campaign is going
to continue to destroy Hamas this war
will end with the end of Hamas because
we cannot allow it to remain in power
and we know that the scenes on our
screens are very difficult and we're
doing everything we can to minimize
civilian casualties but everyone in
Israel understands that the consequences
of inaction would be too great to Bear
because we cannot leave Hamas in power
and our hostages in Gaza we cannot leave
Hamas emboldened to continue attacking
our people to launch another murderous
campaign like it did on October 7th with
those barbaric acts that you have spoken
so powerfully against the burnings the
beheadings the abducting we the Abdu we
simply cannot go back to 6:00 a.m. on
October 7th that will not happen that
Massacre was the straw that broke the
back of a very strong camel and this war
is going to end with the end of Hamas
okay how many uh Palestinians including
Hamas terrorists have you so far killed
we know that we've killed thousands of
terrorists we know hang on okay let me
let me ask you about that so the the
Hamas run health authority says it's
over 14,000 people have now been killed
of that I mean do you a do you accept
those numbers because they have been
endorsed by other bodies but do you
accept that those numbers are fairly
accurate historically they have
been Hamas is the organization the army
of Terror that on October 7th burned
beheaded abducted people and then lied
about it to the entire International
media so it is the opposite of a
credible source and
I but you accept given that previous
figures that they have given during the
many years of his conflict about
casualties have turned out to be pretty
accurate do you accept this is likely to
be the range of people who've been
killed first of all they haven't been
proven accurate because historically
Hamas never admits in the course of a
war that its own terrorists are killed
and that only comes to light afterwards
I'll say what we know about the numbers
and we don't have exact numbers because
Pier I can't tell you how many Israelis
were murdered in the October 7th
Massacre because we still have dozens of
body parts dozens of body bags of
unidentifiable human remains the idea
that I can give you an exact number is
not realistic but here's what I can tell
you one we know we've killed thousands
of terrorists because our campaign has
been targeting to Target the monsters
who perpetrated the October 7 how do you
know they're terrorist we know how do we
know terrorist how do you tell a Hamas
terrorist from a Palestinian civilian
who's not part of Hamas Hamas is making
it very difficult to do that because we
know that it's how do you know you've
killed
thousands because we know who we are
targeting we are targeting on the basis
of precise intelligence this isn't an
indiscriminate bombardment as many would
like to paint it Hamas knows that we do
not Target civilians it seems to know
that better than some in the west that's
why for example we recently Declassified
a an intercepted phone call of Islamic
Jihad terrorists talking about
transporting an anti-tank missile in a
baby's pram because they know perfectly
well that Israel is trying to T not the
civilians my problem with this is that
by your own admission you don't know how
many Hamas terrorists and I I categorize
people who belong to the Hamas
organization as terrorists just for you
know for clarity but you don't actually
know do you how many of them you've
killed and I by your own by your own by
your own admission uh just a few moments
ago you said that they make it
incredibly difficult for you to work out
who is a Hamas terrorist and who is a
civilian that seems to me part of the
problem that you have with the Optics of
this to The Wider world is that they're
seeing horrible imagery all day long I
mean it's it's just the worst thing I've
ever seen all over social media of the
worst thing we've ever seen were the
atrocities at
Hamas yeah I've not seen thankfully I've
not seen what many journalists seen
which is the 45 minute film of that and
I understand it's absolutely horrific
and I'm not making I'm not making any
comparison I would not say anything is
worse than that so for the
uh but the horrible imagery all day long
it is suggesting to people that there
are thousands and thousands of thousands
of women and a lot of children maybe as
many as five 6 thousand children now
have been killed by these uh uh air
strikes and now the ground attack and I
think the problem that you have I say
this respectfully the problem you have
is that you don't actually know how many
Hamas terrorists you're killing and if
you're honest you don't do
you here the sad fact is everyone who
has been killed in the Gaza Strip in the
last month and a half would still be
alive if Hamas had not launched this war
with the October 7th Massacre and then
fought out of densely populated civilian
areas that it has done its danders to
prevent people from evacuating in order
to get to safety while we tried to get
them to safety but I want to say
something about the civilian casualties
because I think this is important we
know that we've killed thousands of
terrorists we know that Hamas is
inflating you don't actually know that
but that's that's my problem with this
you say you say you have but when I push
you for the details you don't have them
and that that for me I still can't tell
exactly how many Israelis were murdered
in the October 7th because we're bodies
don't I agree with you that is utterly
horrific that you still can't determine
how many people were killed that day
because of the horrors that were
perpetrated you and I are in complete
agreement but nor do you know how many
of these Hamas terrorists you're killing
it could be that vast numbers of them
and we think there are around 35,000
perhaps in total that vast numbers of
them either disappeared into the tunnels
and have been safely there ever since or
simply went South with the million or
more Palestinian supposed civilians that
went down there maybe a lot of them
infiltrated that that group and a down
in the South you don't actually know do
you for sure during the Afghanistan war
and I believe your brother a real
military hero fought in that War British
military spokespeople could not have
given you a run running commentary in
real time about exactly how many Taliban
fighters were killed during the second
world war and I know your grandfather
was a war hero who fought the Japanese
to liberate Burma the British army could
not have given a running tally of how
many civilians were killed there or how
many Japanese were being killed these
are facts that become clear when the fog
of War clears and what I can tell you is
that when the fog of War clears and the
numbers become clear about the civilian
to combatant ratio inside the Gaza Strip
and you compare that to other
counterterrorism wars fought by Western
armies like the British in Afghanistan
like the British in Iraq like the
British against Islamic State that ratio
is going to prove very firmly the extent
to which the Israeli Army has gone to
try to keep civilians on the other side
safe from the consequences of their own
DEC their own leaders Reckless and evil
and barbaric attempts to try to keep
them In Harm's Way appears every
civilian casualty is a tragedy civilian
casualties are a feature of every war
and they are a feature of this war that
Hamas began and that Hamas is forcing
the reason I'm pushing the reason I'm
pushing you on it is simply because you
say you've killed thousands of Hamas
terrorists and the reason I think this
is such a an important question is there
have been reports that once this pause
is over that Israel intends to then
attack im a South uh and may give
further warnings to people that out of
certain areas but will attack him the
South and presumably destroy uh the
areas that you attack there as you have
done in the North making it almost
uninhabitable for people to return to uh
and all of this is part of operation get
rid of herass but if the world doesn't
know how much of Hamas you're getting
rid of but only sees day after day hour
after hour images of children dead women
dead innocent civilians caught up in
this then I think the global support for
Israel is going to dissipate very
quickly that's why it's really important
I think for Israel to be demonstrate to
people that your mission is being
accomplished because you know otherwise
you could be here in six months a year
and the civilian death toll in in Gaza
could be over a 100,000 and we might be
having the same conversation when you're
still not sure how many Hamas terrorists
you've killed that's the problem it
seems to me appears I'm slightly
surprised by this question because in
the fog of war no country no military in
the history of warfare could ever give
you an exact running tally I'm an exact
number the casualties but I'm saying we
know that we are targeting Hamas we know
that we are targeting the monsters who
perpetrated the October 7th Massacre and
we know that we are trying to foil their
strategy to hide behind women and
children and just this week we've
exposed the world the evidence of the
bunkers that they built underneath the
shifa hospital that so many have spent
so long trying to cover up and deny that
Hamas is using that strategy let me ask
you what happens the assuming this war
ends and please God it ends sooner
rather than later but assuming it ends
Benjamin Netanyahu has said he intends
to effectively occupy Israel to occupy
Gaza for security reasons indefinitely
what's really what he said indefinitely
you would you would be in charge of
security I mean you're already in charge
of a lot of their food their energy
their water if you start adding security
as an umbrella basically you're
occupying Gaza that is not anything that
anybody wants outside of it seems to me
him and his cabinet I mean it's not what
you would it's not what you would want
is it no Israel does not want to occupy
the Gaza Strip and that is why 18 years
ago Israel left the Gaza Strip so why
would he say why would he say he wants
to do that indefinitely for security
reasons because the sad fact is the
prime minister has said we do not want
to occupy Gaza to say that the Prime
Minister said that is simply false he
said Israel will have to for some period
to exercise security control to prevent
that area being demilitarized just as
President Biden said in his own column
in the Washington Post that there will
have to be how do you do thats how do
you do that we're going to have to
prevent smuggling of any weapons inside
the Gaza Strip after we have totally
destroyed the Hamas Terror
infrastructure you know PS in the years
that Israel has been out of the Gaza
Strip all that concrete that went into
Gaza and was supposed to build people's
houses went into the went into tunnels
all those pipes that were supposed to go
into water pipes Hamas dug them out and
then filmed propaganda videos of them
turning those water pipes and shoting
them at Israel and that is what we have
to prevent to stop this again but if you
displace the vast majority of civilians
as you have and you destroy large
amounts of their homes what do they come
back
to after the day after Hamas and I wish
it were next week but it will take time
there are three things that are going to
have to happen the first is the Gaza
Strip must be demilitarized we will
never allow it to be used as a base for
operations from a terrorist group to
direct attacks against our people just
as the UK and 85 other nations came
together to to deny Isis its territorial
stronghold and they did to R to ra to
raaka and mosle what they did to raaka
and musle because they understood that a
Jihadi group like that must never be
allowed to hold territory to attack
innocent people the second thing is the
Gaza Strip must be deradicalized you
know the youngest terrorists who
perpetrated the October 7th Massacre
weren't even born when Israel vacated
the Gaza Strip in 2005 and they were
raised on a diet to glorify
J third I want to address the question
of reconstruction yeah the Gaza Strip is
going to have to be rebuilt and this
time it's going to have to be rebuilt in
a way that ensures that the concrete
genuinely goes to people's homes and
doesn't go into PE into the tunnels
because otherwise we're going to be in
the same situation sounds very and the
consequences for the only way you can do
all this but with respect the only way
you can do all this is with a form of
occupation whether you want to call it
that or not that's the only way you can
do this and my other question to you
would be this is that is there not a
danger you talk about radicalization
there is there not a danger that the
longer this goes on and the more
innocent people you kill as you try and
Target uh Hamas that you build up a
whole new generation of Palestinians who
are radicalized to hate Israel and want
to exact Revenge isn't that a real a
real concern right now you know I don't
think during the second world war when
the Allies were bombing the Germans and
the Japanese people claim that if you
continue bombing Germans and Japanese
you'll raise a new generation of Nazis
and that's because they realized these
were people who were radicalized beyond
measure and after the war there had to
be a serious process of deradicalization
appears the facts are that 85% of
Palestinians across the West Bank and
the Gaza Strip support hamas's
atrocities on October 7th that is the
first polling evidence that has come out
the level of radicalization is already
severe and it is that radical element
that we have to deny a stronghold from
which to perpetrate atrocities against
our people and we think it's important
that the whole International Community
understand the ex ENT of the rot of the
Hamas death cult that has raised a whole
generation tragically after the greatest
opportunity for peace in the Middle East
that 2005 withdrawal there has to be a
serious push towards deradicalization to
ensure that this never happen again and
we expect the international work hand in
hand with us okay listen I've got to
leave it there but the big question is
whether what you're doing now and what
you intend to do over the next few weeks
and months will actually begin the end
of radicalization or make it a lot worse
and that is a question I think we just
don't know the answer to but Alon thank
you very much indeed for joining me
could I complete an answer perhaps if
you're
quick if this war doesn't end with the
end of Hamas and the return of our
hostages we know that Hamas will attack
us again that's what it says it wants to
do and so if you're talking to me about
extremism we know that a Hamas that
feels emboldened because the world tells
it Israel has no right to defend itself
that is the Surefire recipe for more
radicalism and extremism and more death
and we're determined to put an end to
this cycle of violence and we'll end it
we'll end this war and we'll do it by
ending Hamas he L I really appreciate
you joining me thank you very much
indeed thank you very much Pi anytime on
S next tonight should Israel negotiate
with Hamas or is it simply giving the
upper hand to a terror group that still
has more than 150 hostages under its
control and that of other Islamic groups
in Gaza will
debate
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online run
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver
the Tories love a scrap you can almost
see this coming round the tracks with
sella bravman she's heading up one side
and richy soon at the
other the police are pro Palestine that
is just not right you swear an o in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the ount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin o Solan is the worst presenter on
talk TV sitting on his fat ass talking
for liit
if you're walking towards me and you're
a vegan she have a great big orange
sticker over here saying watch out
vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walked into a
branch of McDonald's MC Mouse man MC
mous man mous man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz
film sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what what what's unfair if
it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to you're going
to resol yes CU I cannot continue my
work when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions are you prepared to call
terror group is it possible to have a
rational I've asked you two questions
should aass stay in power and are there
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV it's the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love poy
we can agree on
that
[Music]
welcome back to un senson Israel is
divided over its hostage deal with Hamas
which has now been extended for a
further two days one major poll found
that 45% of Israeli Jews oppos the
ongoing prisoner swap or just 40%
support it viar benv a right-wing
security minister called it a very very
big mistakes so does negotiating with
terrorists weaken Israel's position or
should Israel's allies be pressing to
make this ceasefire permanent my next
guests have clashed in the past on Miss
show over the crisis in Gaza last time
they appear together I say keeping the
dialogue open is the only way forward
and they both be invited back and so
tonight they're invited back and I'm
joined by Nardin kiswani the activist
and founder of the Palestinian Community
organization within our lifetime and by
the journalist and broadcaster Emily
Austin welcome to both of you Nadine let
me start with you if I may
uh there's a a pause at the moment it's
been extended by two more days there are
hostages being released back to Israel
there are prisoners being released back
to uh the
Palestinians what is your view of where
things should move from
here I think it's important that when we
talk about hostages to also understand
that there are thousands of Palestinian
prisoners that have been held in Zionist
Dungeons and Zionist prisons uh for
years and years and um it's important
that they are also freed and that the
2.3 million Palestinians in GZA uh which
is effectively a concentration camp are
also being held hostage so I think all
hostages um should be freed when we look
at the context of Palestinians prisoners
um and not to call them hostages but
understanding that it's you know the
same uh kind of line of thinking all
right Emily Austin I mean the think
about the Palestinian prisoners you've
been in Israeli jails I was shocked by
not necessarily the age of so many of
them because I knew a lot of young
teenagers in particular had been rounded
up for throwing rocks soldiers and so on
but the fact that so many are being held
in detention without charge that makes
me feel very uncomfortable are you
comfortable with
that um most of the prisoners that were
part of this exchange were actually
tried and you know convicted of the
crimes most of them being attempted
murder there is a narrative going around
that there hasn't been Fair trials that
they haven't been convicted but that's
simply not true and there's one in
particular that's going very very viral
on Twitter of Ahmed al- man al- manra
who was convicted at 12 years old this
is a photo of him then a photo of him
now and they're saying that he was
abused in Israeli prisons but if you
look closely you could see him stabbing
two civilians at 14 years old and a lot
of them are calling this kid innocent
just because he's a child but at 14
years old if you're stabbing civilians
you might be a child but you're
definitely not innocent and contrary to
what nerine just said there is no
equivalency this is not a hostage
exchange this is an exchange of
criminals for children okay these are
babies who are being held captive for
someone who tried to stab the soldier
another baby for another woman who tried
to stab a soldier another baby whose
crime was being a Jew versus another
woman who tried to stab another Soldier
versus another baby whose crime is being
an Israeli who was released for woman
woman who tried to stab a soldier so I'm
sorry this is not a hostage exchange
this is a criminal exchange for our
civilians back who are taken out of
their homes okay Nadine respond to that
thousands of yeah thousands of
Palestinians are held under
administrative detention which as you
said means that they don't even get
charged with anything let alone a fair
trial and that these administrative
detention um you know detentions can be
renewed every 6 months and even when
Palestinians are tried often times
Palestinians are tried in military
courts and there's a 99% or higher than
99% conviction rate of Palestinians
being tried in military courts children
are not tried in military courts
anywhere else around the world um on top
of that Palestinians get 20 years just
for throwing stones now de let me let me
ask you about this question of a
permanent ceasefire Israel just made it
clear to me through their government
spokesman they got absolutely no
intention of having any ceasefire this
war continues in their eyes until they
have have defeated Hamas what is your
response to
that is the murder of 20,000
Palestinians 8,000 of them being
children not enough you know I think
that no matter what they say um no
matter who they're going after there's
always going to be Palestinian
resistance so that argument um is
essentially saying that they're never
going to stop killing Palestinians and
that they're completely justified in
doing so would you categorize H let me
ask you would you categorize what
happened on October the 7th as
resistance
sorry I didn't hear your would you
categorize what happened on October the
7th as
resistance I yeah I would categorize it
um as resistance and it's not my
categorization where that's coming from
terrorism is there any categorization of
Palestinian resistance armed resistance
that you wouldn't categorize as Terror
several thousand people care I think
when several thousand people stor over a
b hang on let me me ji I think when
several thousand people storm over a
border and attack peaceloving people in
a in kutes and butcher them to death
raking people's heads off killing babies
inating were killed by Israel itself
is out that Israel incinerated a
12-year-old
girl but before we get to Israel's
response you must accept that what
happened that day was an act of
terrorism surely
I don't live in a concentration camp and
neither do you and neither does Emily I
haven't lived under the brutal
conditions that the people of Gaza have
had to endure for the better part of the
last two decades it's not up to me to
tell people who are breaking free from a
concentration camp how exactly they
should do that and like I said when
Palestinians tried to do that peace C
they were shot to this is Gaza this is a
very beautiful concentration camp that
is Gaza and it's a damn shame that Hamas
terrorists are invading this very
beautiful looking concentration camp if
only the Jews were that lucky to have
such a beautiful concentration camp
nerine listen Pier let's cut to the
chase stop to condem October 7 stop
asking her to condemn October 7 when she
is borderline a terrorist herself she
herself incites violence she herself
protests and always incites violence and
vandalism even though Vandal vandalism
is not protected by our first amendment
so how do you expect her to demn
terrorism when she has openly said that
it is an act of resistance and she
continues to justify it also want to say
defending palan speaking I was
about I'm not here to De and I don't
care about you either and I'm here to
say I'm just going to keep
speaking each other every single life
that is taken on either side is abhorent
it is atrocious and I wish you would
stop Israel cannot stop until Hamas is
defeated Israel is the only military in
the world that will knock on doors send
out pamphlets send out alarms on roofs
and warn civilians to leave and Hamas
will rather bar civilian psychological
War let ask emages without their mothers
and their let me ask em question Emily
Emily here's my question for you is that
I think there's a real danger for Israel
of this happening sooner rather than
later that if they start attacking the
South as well as seems to be the
intention after this pause is over and
the death toll of innocent Palestinians
continues to Skyrocket and they can't
produce any hard evidence as they
clearly can't at the moment from my last
interview uh of how many actual Hamas
terrorists they're killing in the
process that they're going to lose the
moral support and The High Ground uh and
the the global support for them will
disintegrate for the for Israel that is
a real a real potential danger here I
completely disagree I think it's not is
Israel did its due diligence Israel did
its part they warned civilians to leave
so all of the condemning that Israel is
receiving Kash should be receiving
because they are using their civilian
their their own civilians their women
and their children as human Shields
instead of having them evacuate those
who evacuated we can say the same about
oer
why
the refuges in that should be talk over
each other let me go to Nadine for
response we can say the same about
October 7th October 7th wouldn't have
happened if Israel was not occupying
Palestinian land if there wasn't a seen
blockade on on Gaza if our land wasn't
stolen from us and this has been clear
for so many years Palestinians were
talking about this we protesting about
this for years and years and years while
the world ignored them why why are there
kites next to gaz's border are they a
buffer zone are they human Shields
actually it's Israel that's using
Judaism and using its own citizens as
human sh Shields to Mass Slaughter to
mass genocide Palestinians you can use
all the different terms you want call us
terrorists but it is Israel that has
killed 000 Palestinian children not the
other way around NAD do you believe
hamash should stay in power hang on hang
on Emily should should Nadin Hamas stay
EMP power in
Gaza I believe that Palestinians should
be free that's what I'm here I'm here
I'm here to say that don't answer your
question that's not up to me I don't
live I don't live in I don't you have a
lot of opinions about this is your
opinion that Hamas should stay in power
yes or
no I believe that Palestinians wouldn't
need resistance groups if you're not
going to answer the question all right
Emily no no that is answering the
question actually question given you
several chances no it is answering the
question of course they either stay in
power or they don't there wouldn't be a
resistance group such as Hamas or itself
in power if there wasn't anything to
resist if there wasn't an Israel
can I respond please I want to debunk
this occupation myth once and for all
nine when was the last time Palestinian
had full sovereignty over the land of
Israel when was the last date that they
had sovereignty over the land when was
the last prime minister when did you
have not debunking anything there's
clearly an occupation there clearly a
Sian blockade I'm not here to answer
your question you're genocide you're
justifying on live television the live M
the murder of 8,000 did Palestine have
sovereignty over the land since she
can't answer it from
me called off of our land this your Geno
this is this is Palestinian population
grow is not a gen for generations and
generations a you know the sad thing you
know the sad thing a
genocide the sad thing about this is at
some point we are going to have to bring
the two sides together to reach a peace
settlement and yet every time I bring
people people from both sides of this
debate together this is how it goes it
looks completely imp she's using land as
an excuse to kill let me speak to you I
don't know why you're bringing this
Sports journalist who's obsessed who's
obsessed with making taking theen
terrorist
isan can iish sure call me a terrorist
on live television wonder it was three
Palestinian Americans
who this is I want to say this I want to
say one
thing Americans were shot here on us
soil for wearing a so when you're
calling me a terrorist on TV and say
that there's incitement against you
you're actually
inciting inited violence on myself and
and violence em I'll leave you to both
continue shouting at each other I'm
sorry it ended like that I want to have
constructive debate this doesn't get
anyone anywhere but I appreciate you
both joining me again thank you on TV
next bombshell new book by Megan
loyalist obid lick spit scobby takes
name at every member of the royal
household again but not of course the
Duke and Duchess of Netflix does anybody
in the world believe him I'm going to
reveal something which strongly suggest
you shouldn't um we'll debate this
[Music]
next
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know I
love about to today we do it all sunak
sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police appro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an off in the place
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy there
needs to be one human per machine to
come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes roll unexpected item in
bagging area I know are we only going to
be trusting sources like mattera and
Google where is our unbiased news going
to come from at Gram was president of
the C
which is the rubbish version of being
president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan should have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's about Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this was
important after watching a Tom Cruz
filmm kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solved when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call terror group is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth
[Music]
this is talk
TV welcome back Harry and Megan's
unofficial mouthpiece lick spittle Omid
scobby it's back in the headlines with a
new book endgame scobby and the sisses
deny The inor Hoots as they did with the
last book until Megan was put under oath
and had to admit actually she had
emailed her Aid some thoughts before
they sat down with the authors um which
you might think is being in cahoots well
are they again in cahoots let's discuss
this with author and historian Tessa
Dunlop and Royal commentator Hillary
fordwich so let me start with you Tessa
so given you normally park yourself in
the defending the indefensible about all
things sus what do you think of scob L
just when it seemed like they were
getting off the radar backc scobby uh
with a series of apparently damning
Revelations about all the Royals apart
from the two in Montesito yeah from all
the extracts that we've had access to
and from the interviews that omid's done
in the likes of a par match uh certainly
he's parked his tanks firmly on their
lawn Queen Victoria recommended against
Royals having friendships and if Omid
was once the sussex's friend I bet they
could flick him off like slime right now
because the timing is terrible and I
feel that Omid is actually behind the
curve on this while you've moved on a
bit I think I'll give you credit and
Harry and Megan to an extent I think
after the sort of bomb of the the the
Netflix and the book have been really
quite shum Omi seems to be sort of stuck
in the past well also he's a liar and
I'll tell you how I know he's a liar
because he writes a bit about me in the
book I know I was going to ask you about
that did I got a copy of the book today
and I just checked as you do it's a
digital copy I did a little search up I
come three or four times and on one
occasion he States as a fact that I have
regular phone convers ations with Queen
Camila for the record I have never had a
single phone conversation with Queen
Camila now he says as a fact in his book
that we have regular phone conversations
that I know personally know is an
absolute lie he also says that when I
said on Good Morning Britain that Mega
marle was Princess Pinocchio uh that
apparently she reached out to me Queen
Camila to thank me for standing up for
the firm I had zero contact with with
Queen Camila around that P at all so
you've got no embosed thank you notes
from Camila before she was a queen there
any commun I did however as I said
publicly at the time have conversations
with several other members of the royal
family but it wasn't Queen Camila so my
point let was come to Hillary Hillary I
know personally that just the little
bits about me are completely untrue
they're lies so why should I believe any
of this
stuff well you're absolutely right to
question it I remember the time that you
said that if she uh told you the weather
you wouldn't believe her um a few things
here I would say they say if you're
going to lie be big go bold he States
things so factually that I think your
average person of course they can't sift
through things they don't know that you
know that these were um mistruths and
that bold-faced lies so if he goes so
big people will actually almost assume
it's got to be true I'll tell you
something though here that some someone
that nobody really is mentioning and no
one's talking about and that is Megan
markle's dear friend very close friend
that she's posted online whom she loves
and that is Marcus Anderson well as we
know omed scobby has a very close
relationship to him who knows how much
of this is actually coming from him and
maybe that's the source of a l you whom
he's quing it's a really good point
because we know we know because she went
under oath in a court case Mega marle
had to admit she briefed an aid to then
brief scobby and the co-author and what
about this
there's a point in the book where he
talks about the contents of letters
between King Charles and mega Markle in
which two members of the royal
household I know who they supposedly are
right these two people let's call them
Royal household that two of them had
expressed these Infamous concerns about
the skin color of uh baby Archie before
he was born right but my question is
obviously he's not got that from King
Charles no so he can only have got it
from mean marle or her friends or people
she's told this to right so you know
it's it's two things this book one is
blatant lies secondly stuff he can only
have got from Mega marle it is deeply
unhelpful and poorly Tim from the
sussex's point of view which is why I
don't think they have collaborated with
him recently remember this book's been a
long time in the cooking he started
writing it before the queen died it's
possible that in the wake of the Oprah
wimp Frey interview when tensions were
running High that things did get Spilled
Out that now I expect the pair of that
racism allegation I said this to you
before it never appeared in Harry's book
yeah fact it's never be mentioned again
so they've moved on it's like it never
no it's like it never happened which by
the way is what I said at the time I
don't believe this happened let me go
back to Hillary uh henary what is the
reputation of Megan and Harry in America
right now I mean does do people
care well actually I would say when
Harry bangs on about mental health most
Americans it seems are far more
concerned about the price ofet petrol
here gas and the you know inflation rate
in the US that's the sort of the main
topic of conversation but I will say
this about in the US I tell you an
absolute fact not only can you look at
the polls Pierce but look at the
a-listers look at the Hollywood set
they're not invited to all those A-list
events anymore I think that says a lot
because they're the Bell weather for the
American people the paparazzi here isn't
as interested in them as they were and
look what happened in New York City they
even had to make up that concocted cart
that the mayor of New York Eric Adams
had any who anyone who's been in New
York knew that story was nonsense uh t a
final point we got about 30 seconds he
says this is the beginning of the end of
the monarchy is it no like I say omed
scobby is behind the curve Harry and
Megan will not have wanted this book to
land now they have been very silent
recently they have dropped other the
radar they did make a few mistakes and
they're trying to rebuild meanwhile the
monares had a relatively Good Year all
calm on the Western Front just put along
and I expect
I actually think this might be the end
game for om scobby one of the most loome
little Li spittles in modern history uh
thank you both very much indeed for
joining me tonight uncensored next riots
in Dublin and a hard right populist
sweeps to victory in the Netherlands is
anti-migrant rhetoric stoking and restor
our streets or do people on the streets
actually really care about this issue
Jake Barry Kevin Maguire will
[Music]
debate
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online we on
your smart speaker as well criminals to
using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn do you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swear an o in the
place to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it's hard to know whether
it's a fce or a
tragedy the amount of time it's taken
the number number of illegal migrants
currently sent by us to Rwanda zil the
amount of money it's cost we're saying
what are we saying it's cost about 140
million 140 million so far so £140
million so far result nil absolutely nil
are we only going to be trusting sources
like meta and Google where is our
unbiased news going to come from Kell in
winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegans
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC Mouse
man MC Mouse man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cru
Phil sunac and the current conservative
government are not conservative why
don't you leave that party and come to
one that actually shares your ideology
this has been a party political
broadcast on behalf of the reform UK
party kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve this is
really unfair what's what what's unfair
if it's on camera we're not doing
interviews yes I'm going to do you're
going to Res yes cu I cannot continue my
work when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions are you prepared to call
h a terror group is it possible to have
a rational I've asked you two questions
should aass stay in power and are they a
terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on that
[Music]
welcome back joining me now is the
former chairman of conservative party s
Jake Barry and the daily mirrors
associate editor Kevin Maguire welcome
chat um Kevin I want to talk about
immigration and the effect this whole
debate is having now on European
politics we saw with ger Builders
potentially now running the country in
the Netherlands we've seen you know
Italy go this way we're seeing
authoritarian farri right populist
leaders sprouting up everywhere and a
lot of it is driven at the base of it by
concerned by populace is about
immigration we now see rioting in
Ireland over
a an Algerian actually who become an
Irish citizen attacking three children
and a woman in the street and we saw
terrible rioting but again yeah driven
by this fear of what they believe to be
out of control immigration what do you
think of this and what is the smart way
to handle this yeah I think it's
incredibly dangerous because there has
been this Lurch to the right to the hard
right in Europe and politicians like
Jake will be worried about what happens
in the UK where the level of
immigrations over half a million was
over 34 of a million the net the net
figures which which are which are huge
and I think uh I think politicians have
uh a responsibility to be calm and
reasoned and measured about it uh and
also come up with answers proposals
because what we what we see and now I
hope g g Wilders I think he's got 37 of
150 seats I hope the other parties do
not do a deal with him and those who
finish second and third four for a
coalition maybe with other other parties
because he is so extreme and has spouted
so much poison in the past but look
Europe's going you Europe's going right
in part because of migration well I
think it's a large part of it actually
and and the problem with the migration
debate in this country is that it seems
to me depending who you listen to We
need a lot more migrants to come in but
actually we have too many right in other
words it seems to be both if you believe
all the noise that's going around The
Ether the most I thought the best column
I read about all this wasn't
specifically about migration but it was
a piece by Matthew Paris inmer times
about why so many people are coming in
from abroad they're coming a lot of it
students yes and we're helping out
people from Ukraine and Hong Kong and so
on but also a lot of people are filling
jobs British people simply don't want to
do there are five million people in this
country who now don't want to turn up
and do a day's work and I'm sorry A lot
of them are skyers and they are
manipulating a system particularly it
seems from Matthew paris's piece very
well sourced in the area of mental
health yeah so I mean this is a
challenge across Europe and I think the
other thing we have to accept as
politicians is we're in the foothills of
the migrant crisis this is not going to
go away in fact with things like climate
change and insecurity around the world
whether that be in Europe or in the
Middle East it's it's going to get worse
so politicians need to come up with an
answer to this quick and the answer
isn't the hate ideology sort of pushed
by people like G Builders and other
people on the far right of politics
since we left the European Union the
government controls most of the levers
on legal migration there's things like
the salary cap which is currently 26,200
I mean that's far too if you want High
skilled immigration do not set your
salary cap below the average UK salary
how do we get how do we get the skyers
back to work but you know because
they're clearly gaming the system we've
got to we've got to stop
people bringing uh workers into the
country to to fill low skill jobs at a
lower lower salary than a British do
Kevin that's a quick way you can do it
you can put that up to 40 Grand can and
deal with this very that's not the
problem I'm talking about Kevin the
problem I'm talking about is if we could
just persuade what looks to me like a
workshy country to get back to work
obviously some of them have got
legitimate claims to be off sick but I'm
sorry 5 million people it's crap yeah
going to have to attack a long-term
sickness you're going ill health
disability if you can't do one job can
you do another job I've always several
milon are claiming mental health issues
anxiety and so on right this has got
completely out of control I've always
believed if you can work you should work
and and pay pay your way but there you
will have to have you'll have to have a
Health Service that functions and you
will have to have a lot of counselors
who will be dealing with people who at
the moment say they have problems going
to work and look and not everybody with
a mental illness is making it up no no
no just some because you can't see it
you think it's not I'm sorry it's
several million people basically running
to their doctors and getting signed
challenges for decades we have allowed
you know the answer to low paid work not
to be actually let's invest in
productivity and make that job a higher
paay job let's bring people into the
country to do those jobs that's why I go
back to the point and you're slightly
dismissed it and I'm just going to pick
you up on that cuz I think you're wrong
this idea that you can bring people in
to earn 26 Grand it is wrong it's wrong
for the it's wrong for British people
you want those jobs working things like
Hospital be proper paid jobs you want to
get people off the door give them a I
actually agree with you about that but
on the students thing it's complicated
we want to bring the bright students
into the country to help our
universities who've been struggling
don't let them bring their families in
yeah but who do you leave out of their
families can they bring their wife their
kids both I mean you know these are
serious questions yeah I think it's a
direct dependence close dependence you
can you can bring in you what it say to
me Kevin I don't think the government
has thought through any of policies
students that they they come in they pay
more than a British B to huge amount
huge amounts of money and then they they
go around the world or sometimes they
allow it to stay here but they go around
the world thinking well of Britain it's
a great way of extending final question
is it going to cost them the election to
conservative if they don't get this
right either legal or illegal
immigration now I think the economy and
the fact that most households will be
£1,900 worse off than the last elections
what's going to cost them the election
how big will Immigration it will be a
big issue and what I'd say is the labor
part has got no answer so people I think
will give the Prime Minister and his
team quite a lot of credit for trying to
deal with this the labor party answer is
just actually the labor party the labor
party said end the 20% uh reduction on
you'd agree with labor thank you both
very much it's not easy I doubt thank
you very much that's it for me whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored good
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
talk today we do it all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the tor's love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster Rock gets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police appr Pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of pantomim there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadique Khan we're not stopping
until you
stop the the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million so far so £140 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking Li if you're walking towards me
and you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC Mouse
man MC Mouse man he should be easy
enough to catch this guy shouldn't he I
mean he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film